[Musik]
es geschah an einem sonntag aus heiterem
himmel
innert stunden verlor peter haag sein
betrieb sein lebenswerk
nach unglaublich vor allem das bild das
man so viele stunden verbraucht man
immer viel davon
unglaubliche mengen verzehren mal ein
brand auf dem areal dennis für bisher
israel kanada wo gott sei dank man sie
doch eine schützen vor dem erreichen ist
das mal an johanna maria di bello
insbesondere die zum büro ihnen worauf
mail dialog sich alles von dem hc ist es
klasse wenn er für und der muss es
praktisch verursacher so habe er sich
vorgestellt und klarheit man hin und
wieder als jeder unternehmer hat der
gedanke was wäre wenn aber was steht da
geschah natürlich networker vorbereitet
und gottseidank läuft aber nicht so viel
am 19 august 2012 verdunkelt sich der
himmel über arbon am bodensee
auf dem ehemaligen saurer areal bietet
ein großbrand
[Musik]
160 feuerwehrleute sind im einsatz
menschen leben gibt es keine zu beklagen
aber der sachschaden ist immens
mehrere firmen sind betroffen aber keine
so sehr wie jene von peter harke
[Musik]
wir sind ja unmittelbar vom büro an
erfahren in dem moment aber schlichtweg
nicht möglich sie glauben wir bis zu
fünf meter bin ich nah dran danach und
den nicht so groß war dass man wirklich
nimmer hätte müsse bedenken dass marine
könnte obwohl im büro hat er zu dem
zeitpunkt noch keine bringt da wirklich
noch an und für sich ohne irgendwelche
schuckmann nach china geht aber noch
gerne aber auch nicht zu erhöhen zudem
ist offen ob sie das verursachen
das sind genau versprungen und abacho
und den hang schnell messen
das ganze halt winter weg dann jetzt
hinter mir
der verletzte mann ohne zuschauer sieht
den humor aber vorkommen musste weg die
den einfach aber passiert seine
großhandelsfirma leimholz ag importierte
holz für den schweizer markt ein kleines
lager von peter hacks betrieb blieb vom
brand verschont
[Musik]
ich sag jetzt mit
totalschaden ist also schade gewesen die
sind irgendwie eineinhalb bis zwei
millionen könnte mir vorstellen als mit
genannt dass dort versicherung sind
daheim bereits projekt also müssen
korrekt versichert eigentlich rundum als
auch richtige versicherung staples viel
aber auch nicht irgendwo zu wenig da ich
damals sehr wohl und ich glaube das
funktionierte für sich so war das feuer
im ehemaligen saurer areal ausgebrochen
was war der grund
ein technisches problem oder menschliche
ursache
der chef der thurgauer brandermittler
ignaz lenz sucht nach antworten
das wird ganz genau wisse wo sie auf der
brandplatz rosing wo sind sie angefahren
so willi des strohs hauptgang und den
damit war der konformer der große rolle
phobie und gott herr was büro und wie
investor mit dem gebäude
so hat jedoch so bringt man weiß ist das
auto brannte das alte busfahrer
entstanden ist aber ich denke dass da
gebaut also wenn es brennt nur wenig und
schiebe einer tür klopft vor allem
siebter aber keiner hat sich anna
netrebko und gesellschafter also wir
sind friedlich haben normal büroschluss
card gegangen und ich denke dass sie
sich sogar sicher so dass sie die letzte
zivi wo das büro verlobt wie es
eigentlich üblich ist und da wäre bei
einem viertel für sich sind kritiker dem
viertel von 60 c im moment lang talent
dann wirklich all diesen jahren bank ag
and a d
zu hause bei der familie haag der 49
jährige hat zwei erwachsene kinder aus
der inzwischen geschiedenen ehe tochter
nadja ist 23 und seit zwei monaten
mutter von eli sohn pascal ist 21 und
das ist tags lebenspartnerin marianne
knöpfel vor allem in dieser schwierigen
zeit ist die familie eine quelle der
kraft der studie aber das machen und so
denn ich habe schon immer zu mir
schlafen jetzt keine richtigen komische
das einfach im wasserbad erhitzt
jaja familie
und jetzt das dass momentan so
wahnsinnig auf dem thurgauer
polizeikommando beschäftigen sich die
brandermittler intensiv mit dem
großbrand jetzt beherrschen von
feuerwehrkommandant vorteile zur
verfügung noch relativ in vielen dem
modell der firma work wird der brand
sich entwickelt
eine übung da sie es für unseren
dachrinne sich das breite ton drohende
vitalen ihr und durfte nord sie der
staatlichen überhaupt nicht betroffen
der stets gut so richtig los siete
hallen in mit sie sieht nicht nach platz
sowie das fashion abgesprengt wir das
natürlich super mit dem film mit auch
hannah teter brandherd lag die grenze
bei wetterwechsel zweite finden
in westlichen bereich ja da war der herr
haack sagt der linke siegte anna van loh
nicht für sich sondern es als fotohandy
vastic der heerführer sich das stimmt
wirklich
ok jetzt gehen wir mal die sache nur
zehn erträge stimmen heute massiv dafür
ein ansturm auf komfort den vor den
aufnahmen eindeutig säcke das ist los
gegangen ist wo die firma hs geschäften
hat vor allem die rufe nahmen dauert
hier ist natürlich sehr gut doch sieht
man dass sich aus für außer am gebäude
ist und führung von boddien rufe gott
dazu ist unser tag hin und saic motor
ist noch eine dazu der dachfonds kult
unmittelbar dortmunder unter dem für die
tasten für die halle ist in diesem
bereich
beim ruhesitz überlegt aber für
möglichkeiten wurde brand entstanden
entstanden ist respektive wir stehen
verursacht worden
[Musik]
wenn man setze größere zeit mit haben
wir hinter brandherd in den bereich ok
und vor dem ihr foto und film
der markt wird die holzpalette der uni
brennt und es für quasi ist unter dach
über gott ist 188 ihnen und den santa
cruz können sie sich das vorstellen
varta-führer brandursache ist die wähler
nicht also mir hinter 41 von außen am
gebäude falls für bisschen boden habe
meine sache ich natürlich auch in brand
lag bei eur brandstiftung hängt sie mir
doch irgendwie bestimmt problem
gegenüber innen oder geigenbauer
analytics oder innerhalb von denen
betrieb sind da irgendwelche probleme
man dass da ein die andere würde das
leitwerk und quasi das sind also
innerhalb von dem ihr jetzt da sowieso
nicht mehr in den urlaub fuhr zunehmend
auch wenn januar bis zum riester
absprache untereinander überhaupt nicht
mir persönlich an ist mir absolut nicht
vorstellen weiß nicht wo jetzt so aber
ich glaube nicht dass es den jagen wir
gemacht worden wäre dann hätte mir ganz
andere möglichkeiten zum teil vor der
halle den wert nicht aber wir können gar
nicht telefonieren
sobald ich ein bisschen ja wenn sie ihr
bisheriges modernisierung mini
telefonnummer gut danke
rein theoretisch könnten sie ja den raum
stifters cent aus ja es ist natürlich
jetzt ganz schwierige situation
nervöse workshops brandstiftung und
natürlich jede nie vor und wenn man
jetzt diese frage genau das doch ins
auto trophy ziele das natürlich auch
lieber früh wie ich selber sogar
natürlich dass mit dem brandausbruch
steht also was sich hinter brandstifter
sie das schon recht ein ungutes gefühl
vor allem den wenn man weiß dass man
eigentlich dass ich kann in der mixtur
hat ja was hat über hüte mich geknickt
sie hatten die verleger natürlich gar
kein handy moment aber israel bienert
100 prozentig sicher und ich habe das
auch nicht vorstellen dass never do some
umfeld oder so überhaupt freunde mit dem
werk eröffnet trotzdem sein blick bleibt
nach vorne gerichtet peter haag will
seinen betrieb wieder aufbauen und zwar
hier auf dem brandplatz
nein die so viel erreicht die letzte das
man tagesschluss oberhalb erreichen ist
sich absolut mit ganz im gegenteil es
gibt wahrscheinlich marisa motivation
schweizer dass man auch noch richtig
durchstarten noch mal ein richtiger
organisiert und ist wieder frei stellen
in einer vom feuer unversehrt
gebliebenen halle hat die leimholz ag
ihre geschäftstätigkeit wieder
aufgenommen so sah ich jetzt ist schon
wieder sehr gut berichtet schon nach ein
paar tagen immer wieder computer
installiert und mittlerweile
funktioniert so nahezu 100% mentale
druck
alle computer fax gerät wieder voll im
betrieb und wieder gut die arbeitsplätze
und die gut motiviertes team wieder
richtig gas geht und schaffe die eu
strategie funktioniert wieder
fast gleich wie fahrrad fahren die
bereits trägt der kunde ja auch stunde
hobby ist also sehr sehr schnell viele
aufsteiger schon wieder mal weitersehen
jetzt wenn das glück gerade dass man
auch die edv daten alle wieder gesichert
und wieder hin können zurücklagen auch
ein riesen riesengroße alias trixi das
muss auch ein kleiner ritterschlag
gründete die firma vor 13 jahren sieben
leute arbeiten im betrieb im holzlager
gm arien knöpfe
marianne knöpfel betreut das sekretariat
dank hier konnten die meisten aber nicht
alle computerdaten gerettet werden seit
jahren speichert sie jeden abend die
wichtigsten dokumente auf eine externe
festplatte und nimmt sie mit nach hause
ich bin neutral rechnet max weber da
sieht man natürlich dass man auf trab
halten rechnet forderungen muss die
sache bei der sache ist der auftrag nach
oben auf der daten oder mit onyx viel
abklären gehalt man muss viel weg machen
das moderne sind allen war von anfang an
klar dass es weitergehen wird mit der
firma ja ich kenne peter hug schon lange
bevor wir das geschafft haben
und alle zusammen und ich weiß gar nur
vorwärts und das parken miteinander
hierfür 20 metern 5
abstand
wasser großhandelsfirma für holz
dringend fehlt ist ein gedecktes magazin
wo sind die aufträge da aber ohne waren
an lager zu haben können die kunden
nicht beliefert werden
peter rath möchte auf dem brandplatz so
rasch als möglich ein notzelt aufbauen
lassen
vorläufig dürfen aber die verkohlten
überreste nicht entsorgt werden weil die
polizei noch immer ermittelt gegen das
land sucht nach der ursache des
großbrandes boxen bereit ich dass da
irgendwelche wohl stück sie sind das
thema monate die täterin der braun von
der matratze oder so versprochen sich im
fasching jetzt das ist möglich und ohne
bezüge sind in holzpaletten der
verdauung auf die holzpalette begangen
ist auch nicht genau sagen einfach
wirklich alles verbrennt ich aber sie
sich längere ruhm und es ist möglich
dass auf dem sofa auf dem bohl
stadtausgang nicht von der panik her wo
sie hand ich glaube sie dass ihn manche
ursachen dahinter vor dem brand so
bietet die länge metro will er sich zu
uns die geordnete und die tiefen einer
endrunde geschafft für sowie zuschüsse
losgegangen und der usa einen
flüssigkeitsstrom und henker elektrische
craig venter brand verursacht da vor dem
herrn
wenn man schon davor dass wir irgendwie
ist das fahrlässig oder vorsätzlich dass
der brand entstanden ist
das alte sofa deponierte ein anderer
mieter vor dem gebäude in dem sich hartz
firma befand also die geschädigte
moderne halle jetzt das gemietete und
darin ihre betrieb dahin da sind damit
liege natürlich noch nicht abgeschlossen
aber auch die erste ermutige die wiese
ag dass die elite bis mit dem kranz tour
hängt auch die weiteren ermittlungen
bringen licht ins dunkel als der
auslöser für das inferno war bleibt bis
heute ungeklärt
[Musik]
ende september 2012 ist bei der firma
leimholz die stimmung im keller
peter haag ist zwar erleichtert dass
sich der verdacht auf brandstiftung
nicht erhärtet hat doch jetzt plagen ihn
andere sorgen noch immer keiner die
kunden nicht ausreichend mit holz
beliefern weil ihm ein warenlager fehlt
das geplante notzelt dafür nicht
aufstellen weil der brandplatz nicht
geräumt werden darf der grund seine
inventar versicherung und die
gebäudeversicherung des grundeigentümers
liegen im streit
es geht um die frage wer was entsorgen
muss letzten stelle von jack london
momentan rasch informiert situation wie
sie jetzt offenbar am platz vorne
wir sind in relativ schwierige situation
jetzt definitiv fest dass es nicht
verschickt das mehr nötig
apropos vorläufer eine absprache problem
zwischen den versicherungen und zwischen
dem grundeigentümer nur jetzt einfach
nicht funktionieren da ein chip der
parlamente zu unter anderem andere es
ist nicht schwierigkeit verhütung den
höchsten tagesgewinn zweiter noch
einigermaßen ist aber quer durchs ganze
ich habe zwei bis drei wochen oder in
vier wochen wenn sie mal richtig
schlecht wir haben einfach keine
möglichkeit das material mehr und er
dachte budget dafür ist dass man einfach
nicht mehr lager material können
annehmen dass man jetzt schon kennt und
dass man einfach ja auch zum teil sache
vielleicht einfach nicht gründer
auslieferung schlimmsten fall wenn man
reduzieren oder ich hoffe es nötig haben
wir gas minister die ställe oder so der
glaube jetzt nicht unbedingt aber
erstmal einfach meint reduzieren
es ist wirklich einfach echt unglaublich
schwierige situationen gut danke
[Musik]
noch ahnt peter haag nicht dass sie noch
weit mehr probleme erwarten
ein brand und seine folgen
teil 2 heute in einer woche
[Musik]